you posted a picture this is just a
couple of weeks ago and when you first
posted it I thought it was a let's put
it up I thought it was a picture oh
that's your mom that is you that's you
yeah it is the most stunning yeah
old-age makeup I've ever seen
that's me before I go through the work
[Laughter]
[Applause]
yeah we do that's right doesn't happen
this doesn't happen like that
it starts with I beg to differ I beg to
differ
I've watched you often and seen you
sleeping through the window look what
I'm trying to say is this is you you got
made up to look old they did an amazing
Jets prosthetics of course I'm no
stranger to prosthetics and war a lot
yes that was only one day we were in an
episode of the librarians where we got
stuck in a town where everybody turned
80 overnight and we had to solve the
mystery and in the process we turned
into 80 year olds was fun yeah you know
it's fun I have been in prosthetics
before I don't look like myself and I
love being someone else I like to kind
of walk around and talk to people oh and
say like I'm not I've got conan guy he's
kind of an [ __ ] you know and it's
they always instantly agree but no but
it's fun to be someone else that I you
know it's one of the reasons I became an
actor in the first place I love full-on
transformation
same thing with mystique was sort of the
definition of transformation it's like
the most fun part about what I do for a
living but I loved it I love going
through full-on prosthetic makeup and
you know it's a little claustrophobic
but it's it's fun
you